it's like as part of this is having the
insight is both the easy part in the
magic right you got to have the right
insight it's got to be a big enough idea
but it's also got a beat on the right
time horizon - right I've been talking
about you know we're gonna put computers
in each other's brains for you know
decades at this point and if you go back
20 30 years those people literally were
considered crazy now people are like
that's probably gonna happen but you
know not next year and really somebody's
gonna probably build a big company at
some point around that idea it's just
understanding when and so how do you
think about like why now or it is now
the right time it's it's a great
question so and this is where why we
think inflections are so important so we
like to say there are four types one is
technology which is like Moore's law or
you know sequencing a genome the next is
an adoption inflection you know X number
people use Bitcoin now five years from
now ten X will or 100x or thousand X
will the third is a regulatory
inflection you know now telemedicine
could be practices across straight state
lines will that be permanent you know
new spectrum becoming available for
communications and then the fourth is a
belief inflection and a belief
inflection might be you know now I kind
of think I would like to do most of my
doctor's appointments on telling this
and now that I've had to do it a few
times it's not so bad
and you know doctors and patients are
starting to think that so like a good
wine example from a company we invested
in lift the technology inflection was
the GPS locators in smart phones became
10 times more accurate with the iPhone
3GS it but if you'd if you'd had the
idea for left or uber but you tried to
launch it before that was true wouldn't
it matter that your idea was right it
would have been too early because the
service wouldn't have worked right but
then the other component of the why now
was the adoption
election we could say okay it's 2010 10%
plus or minus have smartphones will more
than 50% have smartphones in three to
five years or like that you know you
could see that'd be impossible it so you
say okay now let's let's look out into a
world where most people have smartphones
that you can locate precisely maybe now
you can create a transportation network
but whereas you couldn't have done it
before and if you'd waited another
couple of years you'd have been too late
somebody would have gotten the jump on
you and built a network effect before
you could have yeah and then I guess the
last part of this kind of insight
component is how big the insight is
right and and the reason why that's
important is if you think about there's
a lot of investors who they just say
look the right markets the team can be
actually subpar the market will win and
kind of carry us some part team maybe
it's a little bit of an exaggeration and
you need a you know above-average team
in a great market so one would love to
know your opinion on that but also to
just how do you know that this market
will be big enough if they can actually
pull this off
where it can drive the types of returns
that make the power loss of a venture
fund work yeah so the first thing I'd
like to say about market is when it
comes to startups most people in my view
misinterpret what a market even really
is so in a company people tend to look
at a market as something that you can
map it's like I'm Lewis and Clark I'm
gonna map all the tributaries of the
Mississippi River and I'm gonna say how
high the mountains are where the trees
are all this stuff where the Indians are
you know where where the arable land is
that's that is a way to think of markets
if you're living in the present working
at a big company startup markets or
movements and movements are started by
time travelers living in the future
coming back to the present with a secret
about the future and they enlist other
people initially who believe their
secret and they start a movement and the
market is a consequence of the move
accelerating and so as more and more
people start to buy into the insight of
the founder of the visionary founders
the conventional wisdom and belief
shifts to the point of view of the
founders and then there's this tipping
point where the market tips and now
people in the present think that's a
market they start mapping it they do all
the traditional things but so the reason
that I think that's important is that
the mistake that I think some of my
fellow investors make is they ask what's
the town you know the total available
market and I'm like that's a myth when
you invest in a start-up there there is
no market the question is is the insight
powerful enough that a massive movement
could start around it that will change
the world
and so the insides like the Archimedes
lever of that founder who's gonna move
the world and they're gonna start out
small and by the way most people are
going to disagree with them at first
right good insights most people won't
like it because most people live in the
present so you're trying to you're
trying to the best startups I have ever
been involved with our founders in on a
secret that's right venture people who
believe their secret early customers who
believe their secret and they all go to
war together and make this mission
happen which becomes this gathering
movement and and in the market itself is
the accumulated enthusiasm and energy
behind the movement